>> Well, this has been quite the family adventure, for some more than others.
>> It's definitely been a bit exhausting.
>> But I love learning how connected we all are and how many
cousins I have. I'm going to have to print more holiday cards this year.
>>
[LAUGH]
Well, I do find it amazing, the
conceptually elegant process of mutation and natural selection
that drives evolution. Creating all of perfections
and imperfections that we share through common ancestry.
>> I mean I love what we've learned so far, but where do we go from here?
>> Well, I think it's time we turn
to each other and try to apply this knowledge.
In the next and final lesson, we're going to
see how different professions use genetics to actually do
their jobs. And then we're going to see the societal implications behind it.
>> I'm ready to apply this knowledge. Let's do it.